it's a start uh we still got three games
you know uh it's a start we know it's a
four game season and then tonight was
one
um obviously we got a we had a great
road road test next weekend and
we gotta get prepared for another
another opportunity
you know when doug peterson said they
got a great road test next weekend it's
like wait wait are they playing like the
steelers in pittsburgh they're playing
washington on the road but but look it's
the way they've played recently
they've played recently yes every game
is going to be a test because the bottom
line is this
the eagles were down 14 points in the
first half to a team that had lost eight
games in a row and but for the eagles
heroics it wouldn't have gone to nine so
the eagles find a way to win i mean
this is amazing to me this division is
so bad this year at a time when the rest
of the nfc is so good that's what makes
it so glaring you've got one group of
four teams in the nfc
that is horrendous the other three
groups of four teams pretty darn good
especially two of them the north and the
west and the eagles to their credit
stayed the course yes they fell behind
and yes eli manning and darius slayton
looking like a very promising connection
for the future the only problem is eli
manning's not going to be there beyond
the next three weeks
it was looking good for the giants it
was clicking it was working and it was
not looking good for the eagles they got
booed off the field at halftime what a
shocker that that would happen but they
did pull it together in the second half
carson wentz for the first time in his
career chris wins an overtime game and
he did not have much help around him
nelson aguilar was injured al shawn
jeffery left with a lower leg injury
which very well may be a torn achilles
tendon they had guys out of position
they had rather had boston scott in it
running back for a big chunk of the
second half and he had over 120 yards
from scrimmage on the game i mean it
worked out very well for the eagles they
kept pushing they kept plugging they
tied it up late and then didn't it seem
to you like on the first drive of
overtime the giants were just ready to
go home well yeah like the eagles you
know it's just like that's it we're done
we we hey we we got we got kind of a tie
here we we had 17 and they had 17 at the
end of regulation that's good enough for
us well yeah i do think you're right
about that the new york giants in the
second half i mean their defense was on
the field the whole the whole second
half so i think when overtime came
eagles win the toss and get the ball
they were exhausted i mean they just
they were beaten into the ground at that
point you know the offense of the giants
just fell apart in the second half but
you know getting back to what you said
about the eagles man there's so many
things to say first off carson
carson wentz good for him you know again
he's taken a lot of criticism there in
philadelphia and i don't think it's
really justified i don't i mean you know
again there's just not a lot of talent
around him i don't know what anybody
expects everybody tells me oh he needs
to play better oh he needs to play
better and yeah i know he could play a
little bit better sure but it's not like
he's missing wide open receivers all
over the field i mean we didn't see any
replays last night or anything that said
oh wow yeah they missed that he missed
that guy he missed that guy every throw
he throws is into the tightest coverage
you've ever seen and if he doesn't put
it right below the guy's chin they can't
do anything
having said that it was really good to
see him battle i don't know if i even
i have great respect for the eagles but
man i don't know if i want to watch them
in the playoffs right now i don't i mean
i just you know i it almost makes me
want to root for dallas just because at
least they got some star power and some
potential
but
man i mean what do you say the defense
crappy in the first half offense even
though they got it together in the
second half it was i mean just a
a a a fight i mean it was so grueling
and hard everything they did and i just
i don't see how they can make any run in
the playoffs and that's why uh it's just
a little disappointing to watch a team
like that get in if they do get in
and you got to give them credit because
they got the ball in the fourth quarter
they started the drive inside their 20.
there was a sack on the first play right
they had a long way to go and they just
kept plugging away and plugging away
and and it looked like they were going
to time it just right that they would
score the game tie it up right at the
end of regulation all of a sudden it's
like hey you're going to leave the
giants with enough time to try to go
down and win this in regulation of
course
they're the giants and
they weren't able to move the ball very
effectively throughout the second half
and definitely not on that last
opportunity so it all worked out
perfectly for the eagles they stepped up
when they needed to
and they won a game it's just critical
at this point for the cowboys or the
eagles to win a game and now the eagles
have washington on the road the cowboys
at home and then they're at the giants
to end the season the cowboys have the
rams this weekend you know the cowboys
could lose and the eagles win the eagles
have a one game lead going into that
week 16 showdown sure that could happen
yeah that could happen either way i feel
like week six nothing else matters other
than week 16 cowboys and eagles whoever
wins that game is gonna win the division
and if it's the cowboys you know if they
go into that game tied and the cowboys
win then the cowboys will have it
clinched and they can rest their
starters for week 17 and they can be
ready for whoever rolls in in the wild
card round and it just wouldn't it be
fitting that whoever wins this awful
division ends up parlaying home field
advantage into beating the five seed
whoever the five seed may be well it
would be crazy it really would be uh and
you know again as of watching the eagles
the last few weeks and watching last
night i don't see how they could do it i
mean come on you know i follow football
for a living i'm obsessed i had to sit
there with a few guys on the field going
oh wait who is that oh yeah i remember
him from the preseason oh oh yeah i kind
of remember him when he came out in the
draft i mean they got no names out there
right now
and then the defense you know again the
first half i mean what what do you say
about the defense how let's come out
with the game plan to make it the
easiest on the quarterback who hasn't
played in 11 months let's just play man
to man every play so they can throw a
slant and a go route and just do that
don't make the guy who hasn't played
actually think or have to worry about
anything make it for the guy that's
played for 16 years make it as easy as
possible for him to get back like it's
practice i mean that's basically what
they did in the first half and credit to
eli manning he came out and was smart
got the ball out of his hand through
some accurate passes darius slayton is
good uh but the second half the eagles
had a different approach finally i mean
finally i don't know what was going on
it's their only chance is to throw the
ball to darius sladen and one-on-one
coverage and the eagles are like here
here's a silver platter we're going to
let you throw it to him and when we do
double him we're going to do it so
stupidly uh that he's just going to run
by both of us there and and you know of
course i think they bench ronald darby
in the second half and uh the game plan
at least changed that way to where the
defense stymied the giant's offense and
the eagle yeah and the eagles offense
kind of got it going
and with only 12 minutes at halftime you
don't have an extended opportunity to
get everything on the same page and make
the changes you need to go into the
second half and get things done and the
eagles did get booed off the field and
they and they if i'd have been there as
an eagles fan i'd have been booing as
loudly as i could it was a horrible
production in the first half but doug
peterson here he is explaining that at
halftime there was no yelling there was
no screaming it was just focus on doing
what they had to do to turn this thing
around here's peterson
you guys think i'm crazy but it's not a
it's not a shouting match in there you
know we're not throwing stuff and
getting getting all up in arms at each
other we're coming together we're
figuring it out we're putting a solution
together
you know we talked about hey defense big
possession to start you know three and
out and they did and
uh offensively it took us a few series
but we finally got it going and it's
just a matter of that
carson once had a bad first half second
half in overtime 22 of 31 228 yards and
a couple of touchdowns and and look i i
have to give the eagles credit and i'm
trying to find hope that if they do
qualify for the playoffs there's reason
to actually watch the game and think
that they have a chance of winning and
won't lose 52 to 10 to the seahawks or
the 49ers well yeah well what's the hope
i i don't know i mean you know again
that's where i just get into it i i
really like i ask you like what do you
think who do you want to see
right now i mean i don't want to see the
philadelphia i don't see any of them
well i don't want to see the eagles
cowboys
like take away the playoff birth a live
a live reality drama show the dallas
cowboys and have stars all over the
field i'd rather watch that than watch
the eagles right now i mean just
everything is it's just impossible it's
tough you know there's no they don't
have a receiver mic they don't know i'm
not sure they have a receiver on the
field right now that runs much faster
than you and me i'm not even joking and
you know and then now alshon jeffrey who
was not fast to begin with he's off the
field you know zach gertz is the only
guy that can catch a ball uh
consistently and you know he's not
exactly explosive either wherever he
catches it you can kind of just spot the
ball he's gonna go down right there the
running backs okay they found a little
juice there finally uh at the end of the
football game you know the defense is
all over the place every week i mean
right now yeah i'm gonna root for the
cowboys just for a good tv watching as a
football fan i respect the hell out of
the eagles and doug peterson but you
know the product on the field is just
not up to par right now and they do not
have it going and uh i'd rather watch
the cowboys in the in the wild card
weekend than the philadelphia eagles
and for that reason you know that the
nfl generally is hoping the cowboys win
that division because they're going to
draw millions regardless of whether they
jump in it's seven and nine right right
and and it is a more interesting team to
watch i agree with you and also look
it's a given that jason garrett's gonna
be gone after the season unless he
really does pull one hell of a rabbit
out of his hat and if they don't make it
to the playoffs he's going to be fired
at the same time four or five other guys
are fired so i guess you push it back a
week and you have you have a news cycle
where you can focus on what the cowboys
are going to do next and and the press
conferences and all of that so it comes
after the wild card round i guess from a
from a media business standpoint it's
better to stretch that out so i agree
with you
for selfish purposes we're rooting for
the cowboys although
we've seen the eagles each of the last
two seasons yeah become a different team
when we write them off in the playoffs
two years ago they got the underdog
masks out they were they were underdogs
at home in two playoff games they were
underdogs in the super bowl they won all
three games and last year they were done
they were four and six and they ended up
making it to the playoffs and almost
making it back to the nfc championship
game they had the saints on the ropes
early but couldn't hold on so i feel
like the cowboys are the more
interesting team
in the wild card round but i feel like
the eagles have a better chance of
winning because you get doug peterson
and company into a single element
something like that who cares if we're
seven and nine right they know how to
win games they're not supposed to win
chris yeah they do there's no doubt
there's an art to that that you know
you've said it a lot of times the
ultimate backs against the wall type of
football team and man did they really
wait till they're crammed in a corner
last night i mean holy crap i mean not
only was it a must-win game but then
they're down 17-3 to a team that like
you said hadn't won in eight weeks uh
but but i just think it's a little
different than the last two years i do
just because the the health of the team
is just not the same you know last year
they got healthy right at the right time
when nick foles took over and that
allowed them and propelled them to go to
a little bit of a playoff run and have
the upset in chicago the year before
come on they were the best team in
football and it was just carson wentz
that went down this year i just don't
know where they can generate the offense
uh the defense is so hot and cold and
all over the place really i thought the
defense had gotten it together until the
the until to the miami game and then of
course last night in the first half but
i hear what you're saying but i just i
can't imagine that they can replicate
that magic we've seen the last two years
do you expect for the golf organization
to give you a chance to finish on this
season regardless
yeah i do
but
we'll just have to wait and see won't we
we got a lot of tough ones for me today
well pat that's what happens when you
lose nine games in a row tying a
franchise record the question is will he
be around to try to break the record on
sunday when the dolphins come to town
i think he will be chris i don't get the
impression he's going to be fired now uh
maybe maybe part of the punishment is
you have to go ahead and finish this one
out and see if you can get to 12
consecutive losses and extend the
franchise record three games beyond what
it previously was but you know it's it's
almost a foregone conclusion now this is
not sustainable that's right the
question is when does john mara and
steve tish decide and steve tish has
already said end of the season is when
they're gonna take it up but uh this is
bad this is bad and last night i think
the fact that they were up and they blew
the lead makes it worse than the garden
variety loss yeah i i totally agreed and
uh totally agreed in the fact that yeah
i think it's already you know in the
books i i do i think pat sherman will
not be the giants head coach when the
season ends they're going to let him
finish it out certainly you know i don't
even think that's a question anymore i
think the question now is is dave
gettleman around still as the gm to go
along with it or they totally clean
house i mean that to me is the next
thing but uh as far as patch shimmers
run yeah i do think it's over mike
gellerman's best play would be selling
ron rivera as aggressively as he can
because he worked well with rivera in
carolina and that would maybe be the way
to keep gettlemen in place otherwise he
could be gone as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports